oh yeah uh wesley calculating extremely
well there
um it looks like he did give up a pawn
temporarily black's weak pawn has
actually just dropped off the board but
the knights have disappeared
at the same time and um oh look at
magnus he realizes this is a blunder
what's happening wow totally
just blunders his queen it took me a
while to spot as well that was visually
very difficult to spot but
oh no he is extremely angry is this lost
now
yes that's lost and magnus just didn't
have enough time that's an
uncharacteristic blunder he blunted his
queen because
he didn't keep the white king safe on
the background we'll show that later on
but
right now black is up a queen for just a
rook wesley so
is about to guide this to a win and
magnus
we saw it on his face right i mean we'd
never see in blunder like that
like that no but it was a very neat
tactical shot i'm
didn't come naturally and uh
well there you can see here world
champion is just furious with himself
there's just nothing to do here i mean
the just
one rook is totally insufficient against
the black queen
and uh black queen passive for now but
over the next few moves she's going to
get active yeah i mean she's going to
overwhelm the white rook big threat
right now that you can
just take the pawn and well wesley
playing
super safe he doesn't give magnus any
chances
whatsoever and there's nothing that the
white risk can do
yeah white's rooks are stuck passive
defending one of their own pawns
magnus is just gonna hope that wesley
maybe panics under time pressure but
look at that the queens are so versatile
so agile
black's queen she retreats she steps
back but she attacks a pawn in the
middle
attacks the pawn in the center and
wesley can just take a pawn with this
queen if he wants right now
no real risk in this position for wesley
so
yeah this one is it's almost game over
but the clock is the only thing that
could turn this around for magnus
right now retreating his rooks and
at least he has one pawn alive on that
left side maybe
in a dream world magnus can push that
pawn forward and cause some
nuisance magnet wesley says no he's
going to go for the counter-attack and
yeah i mean what we're going to see now
is the rook and the queen aligned
together to create and now you can just
simply go rook takes
pawn or is that not working there are
some tricks in the position i think
wesley
can just play rook takes pawn right now
magnus he's getting ready to resign
wesley finishing this one off with a
nice trick and we'll just see a set of
rook traits blackwood stop white's pawn
magnus he's getting ready to resign now
black's queen stopping white's pawn
that's the last glimmer of hope no more
counter play for white